à première vue c'est un petit lac comme
bien d'autres pays mais c'est désormais
un symbole mondial celui de
l'anthropocène sa veut signifier
l'époque le temps
ou la Terre a été affectée complètement
par les activités humaines pour ces
géologues qui étudient les changements
environnementaux provoqués par notre
espèce ont irrémédiablement modifié les
sols terrestres
ils ont été mandatés avec des collègues
du monde entier pour déterminer si ces
modifications méritent d'être reconnues
comme une phase distincte de l'histoire
de la Terre et on a été chargé de
chercher s'il y avait un signal qu'on
trouvait dans les dans les roches de la
terre de ce changement
ce signal ils l'ont trouvé au fond du
lacroford dans ses couches de sédiments
uniques dans ces couches qu’on appelle
des verves ils ont pu détecter entre
autres des traces de la d'hydrocarbures
ou des rejets nucléaires au fil du temps
à conclure que l'époque anthropocène
aurait commencé au milieu du 20e siècle
quand l'économie a bondi après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
elle viendrait s'ajouter au haut de
l'échelle chronostratigraphique des
géologues leur calendrier de l'histoire
de la Terre découpé en air en période en
époque avec des noms comme mésozoïques
crétacés ou jurassique
mais la proposition est loin de faire
l'unanimité pour bien des experts on n'a
pas encore assez de recul pour
déterminer si les impacts des humains
laisseront des traces de l'ordre de
celles qu'on mesure à d'autres époques
vieilles de milliers voire de millions
d'années
n'a pas fini de faire parler de lui
ici Gaël Lucia berdoux Radio-Canada
Montréal